C'est avec joie, pour moi en tout cas, que nous revenons ce matin dans le deuxième chapitre de la lettre de Jacques.
Nous avons passé les trois dernières prédications à constater, dans les versets 1 à 7 que nous venons de lire,
à quel point l'acception de personne est un péché grave.
Et nous allons aujourd'hui nous pencher sur le sujet de la loi, au verset 8 à 11.
Jacques ne revient pas en détail sur l'acception de personne dans ses versets 8 à 11,
mais il requalifie cependant cette attitude de péché, au verset 9.
Et donc sans revenir sur tout ce que nous avons développé durant les trois dernières prédications,
il me semble important de vous rappeler en quoi le favoritisme ou l'acception de personne est en effet un péché,
un péché grave, qui est totalement incompatible avec le caractère de notre Dieu,
la nature et la mission de son peuple, l'Église, est incohérent avec les principes de l'Évangile
que nous professons et que nous cherchons à mettre en pratique.
Donc laissez-moi tout d'abord vous rappeler ce qu'est l'acception de personne
telle que nous l'avons définie à l'aide de cette première verset du chapitre 2.
L'acception de personne, que l'on peut aussi appeler favoritisme ou partialité,
est un grave péché qui consiste à accorder plus de considération à une personne ou à un groupe de personnes
sur la base de critères charnels, selon ce qui frappe les yeux,
plutôt que selon les critères de Dieu qui lui regarde au cœur et qui sont la justice,
la vérité, la grâce, la miséricorde, l'amour, bref, les principes de l'Évangile.
Lorsque nous accordons un traitement de faveur à une personne,
en nous basant sur une échelle de valeurs humaines,
sur des critères charnels qui sont vains, qui sont mondains,
nous rendons évident que ce que notre cœur aime, désire et recherche véritablement,
c'est sa propre gloire.
Car nous montrons par là qu'il y a à nos yeux des personnes
qui sont supérieures à d'autres parce qu'elles possèdent telle ou telle chose
qui, à nos yeux humains charnels, les rendent plus dignes d'être honorées.
Plutôt que de tous nous voir comme Dieu nous voit,
c'est-à-dire comme des pécheurs,
gracieusement déclarés et rendus juste en Christ,
tous profondément misérables au départ et infiniment dignes à l'arrivée,
nous continuons de nous comparer les uns aux autres
selon des critères charnels
qui devraient tous pourtant avoir disparu derrière la gloire éclatante
de notre Sauveur Jésus-Christ qui enveloppe chacun de nous.
Lorsque nous faisons exception de personne,
nous honorons les personnes qui possèdent ce qui donne selon notre chair,
selon ce qui frappe nos yeux de la valeur à quelqu'un.
Et cela montre que c'est aussi et d'abord ce que nous voulons pour nous-mêmes.
Car qui d'entre nous vante les qualités d'une personne sans chercher à posséder ces mêmes qualités ?
Si je pense que cet homme est digne d'honneur parce qu'il est riche,
bien entendu qu'au fond de mon cœur je souhaite être riche.
Si je pense que cet homme est digne d'honneur parce qu'il parle bien ou parce qu'il est beau,
bien entendu qu'au fond de mon cœur je souhaite bien parler et être beau.
Lorsque nous honorons la gloire charnelle de notre prochain,
nous montrons donc que nous cherchons en réalité notre propre gloire charnelle.
L'acception de personne, c'est la preuve d'une convoitise de gloire personnelle dans le cœur de celui qui commet ce péché.
Et qui a-t-il de plus proche du caractère du diable lui-même
et de plus éloigné du caractère de Dieu que la recherche de vaines gloires personnelles ?
Pour comprendre à quel point l'acception de personne est un péché grave,
il faut comprendre à quel point cette attitude est similaire à la stratégie que Satan lui-même a mis en place
et continue de mettre en place pour faire chuter l'homme.
C'est en effet Satan qui fut le premier à convoiter l'adoration que Dieu recevait de ses créatures
en réponse à sa gloire infinie.
Mais il a pris bien vite qu'aucune créature ne peut convoiter et encore moins voler cette gloire
et cette adoration qui ne peuvent revenir qu'à Dieu seul.
Et donc, ne pouvant s'élever jusqu'au trône de Dieu et s'y asseoir,
Satan trouva un autre moyen de satisfaire sa soif de gloire personnelle.
Rabaisser, dominer et contrôler les créatures de Dieu
en redirigeant leur adoration vers lui par la ruse, le mensonge et la force.
Et quelle meilleure cible pour cette stratégie que la plus belle des créatures de Dieu ?
La seule conçue à l'image de son créateur, la seule capable de lui rendre un culte, l'homme.
Satan mit donc en place une stratégie sournoise
pour prendre la place de Dieu dans le cœur de ses adorateurs créés à son image.
Il fit semblant de vouloir le bien de l'homme.
Il le flatta dans le jardin alors qu'il cherchait en réalité à l'abaisser
et à lui faire le plus grand mal en le séparant éternellement de son créateur.
Et quel sentiment de victoire Satan dut ressentir lorsqu'il réussit,
lui le père du mensonge,
a poussé la femme et l'homme à travers elle à désobéir à leur Dieu
et à imprégné leur nature humaine de son esprit mauvais,
totalement hostile à l'esprit de Dieu,
jusqu'à en faire ses adorateurs et plus que cela,
jusqu'à en faire ses enfants,
comme le dit la parole.
Mais des enfants mal aimés,
maltraités,
abusés,
des outils uniquement destinés à assouvrir sa convoitise de gloire personnelle
et sa haine de Dieu.
Et c'est exactement ce qui est à la racine du péché d'acception de personne.
Lorsque nous favorisons le riche par rapport au pauvre,
l'influent par rapport au marginal,
le beau par rapport au lait,
l'éloquent par rapport au bafouilleur,
nous ne faisons que montrer que nous avons encore en nous
cet esprit de Satan
qui cherche à s'élever égoïstement et égocentriquement
au-dessus des autres
et à leur détriment.
Nous voulons être riches,
influents,
beaux, éloquents
et nous voulons que les autres le remarquent
et nous complimentent,
nous flattent pour toutes ces qualités qui frappent les yeux
comme nous le faisons envers ceux qui possèdent
ces mêmes qualités.
Voilà ce qui, en réalité,
pousse un homme charnel
et même un chrétien parfois
à faire acception de personne
et cela est un grave péché
qui caractérise les enfants du diable
et ne peut caractériser les enfants de Dieu.
Et c'est évidemment parce qu'elle est un péché aussi proche
du caractère et de l'attitude de Satan
que l'acception de personne
est si incompatible
avec le caractère et les œuvres de Dieu
et donc de son peuple
qui est appelé à refléter le caractère
et les œuvres de Dieu.
Nous avons eu l'occasion de considérer
de nombreux versets très clairs à ce sujet
dans l'Ancien comme dans le Nouveau Testament.
Dieu se présente lui-même
comme le défenseur de la veuve et de l'orphelin,
comme celui qui les vengera
contre les riches et les puissants
qui les abusent et les oppriment.
L'Église, dès ses débuts,
est encore à ce jour
majoritairement composée d'hommes,
de femmes et d'enfants
humbles,
matériellement et même intellectuellement.
Jésus-Christ ne rendit-il pas grâce
lui-même à son Père en disant
« Je te bénis, Père, Seigneur du ciel
et de la terre,
d'avoir caché ces choses aux sages
et aux intelligents
et de les avoir révélées aux tout-petits. »
Jésus-Christ est le Sauveur et le Seigneur
de ceux qui se reconnaissent
comme étant pauvres en esprit,
des affligés, les débonnaires
de ceux qui ont faim et soif de justice
parce qu'ils sont opprimés.
Voici le genre d'instructions
qu'il nous laisse à nous, son Église.
« Quand tu donnes un repas,
invite des pauvres,
des estropiés, des boiteux,
des aveugles
et tu seras heureux
parce qu'ils n'ont pas de quoi
te rendre l'appareil. »
Une instruction qu'il n'est pas étonnant
de retrouver au premier chapitre
de cette lettre de Jacques.
La religion pure et sans tâche
devant Dieu, notre Père,
consiste à visiter les orphelins
et les veuves
dans leurs afflictions.
Tout comme notre Dieu aime
et prend soin
des plus misérables,
nous sommes appelés, nous aussi,
à les aimer
et à en prendre soin.
Tel est l'appel,
telle est la mission
de l'Église du Christ.
Car n'est-ce pas ce que Dieu
fit avec chacun d'entre nous,
quel que soit notre statut social,
nos qualités
ou nos accomplissements
dans cette vie ?
Peu importe notre situation individuelle,
nous avions tous en commun,
comme nous l'avons entendu
en ouverture de ce culte,
d'être spirituellement pauvres,
misérables,
hideux
et totalement démunis.
Et pourtant,
Dieu s'est approché de nous,
il a relevé notre tête,
nous a lavés dans le sang
de son propre Fils,
revêtus de son manteau
de justice immaculée,
mariés à son Fils
et adoptés dans sa famille
et donnés son nom.
Tel est le message
et l'effet de l'Évangile.
Dieu se révèle
aux misérables rebelles
que nous sommes,
nous révèle à quel point
nous sommes misérables
et pécheurs,
à quel point nous avons
besoin d'être sauvés
par Christ
et restaurés
à l'image de Christ.
Il fait de nous
ses fils et ses filles
dans son palais royal
pour l'éternité.
Tout ce que nous sommes
aujourd'hui en tant
qu'enfants de Dieu,
toutes les bénédictions
spirituelles,
temporelles et éternelles
que nous possédons,
nous les avons reçues
de la main du Père
par le Saint-Esprit
en vertu de l'œuvre
accomplie de notre Sauveur
et Seigneur Jésus-Christ.
Car vous connaissez
la grâce de notre Seigneur
Jésus-Christ,
lui qui était riche,
il s'est fait pauvre
pour vous,
afin que par sa pauvreté
vous soyez enrichis,
nous dit l'apôtre Paul.
Et Jacques,
Dieu n'a-t-il pas choisi
les pauvres aux yeux du monde
pour être riche en la foi
et héritier du royaume
qu'il a promis à ceux
qu'il aime ?
Voici ce qui est clair
dans toute la parole de Dieu,
dans tout le Nouveau Testament,
dans les lettres de Paul
et dans la lettre de Jacques.
C'est selon sa seule volonté,
par sa toute puissance
et dans sa grâce
que Dieu transforme
notre cœur de pierre
en cœur de chair.
Il nous fait naître de nouveau,
nous fait passer
du royaume des ténèbres
au royaume de son admirable lumière
et nous donne la puissance
de combattre le péché,
de le vaincre,
d'obéir à sa loi
par son Saint-Esprit
qui vit désormais en nous.
Dieu fait de nous ses enfants
avant de nous appeler
à vivre comme ses enfants
le doivent.
L'obéissance après la grâce,
les œuvres après la justification,
la sanctification après la régénération,
cet ordre logique est crucial.
Je le répète presque
à chaque prédication
dans la lettre de Jacques
et cela deviendra
de plus en plus important
alors que nous nous rapprochons
des versets les plus polémiques,
dirons-nous,
de cette lettre
dans laquelle certains ont vu
ou veulent voir à tort
un enseignement différent
de celui de Paul
au sujet de la place
des œuvres dans la vie chrétienne
et plus précisément
dans notre justification.
Et sans parler uniquement
de ces versets,
c'est vrai que la lettre de Jacques
est remplie d'exhortations
à l'obéissance,
à la mise en pratique
de la parole,
aux ailes pour les bonnes œuvres.
Et donc,
si on ne prend pas le temps
de rappeler l'ordre
dans lequel s'imbriquent
tous ces aspects
de notre vie chrétienne,
nous pouvons facilement tomber
dans ces deux grandes erreurs
opposées que sont
le légalisme
et l'antinomisme.
Et c'est un rappel
particulièrement pertinent
pour les versets 8 à 11
qui sont devant nous ce matin
car Jacques,
il parle très explicitement
de loi,
de commandement,
d'obéissance,
de transgression,
de culpabilité,
de condamnation,
de jugement.
Et donc,
avant de nous plonger
dans ces exhortations
qui concernent directement
notre rapport à la loi,
il est important
que vous ayez bien en tête
le fait que Jacques est un pasteur
qui écrit à des chrétiens
pour les encourager
à rester fidèles à l'Évangile,
aussi bien en connaissance
qu'en pratique,
malgré les expériences
très dures et douloureuses
qu'il traverse,
notamment à cause
de la persécution,
et qui pourraient,
comme ce fut malheureusement
le cas pour plusieurs,
les pousser à renier
leur foi en Jésus-Christ.
Quelle place la loi occupe-t-elle
dans notre vie de chrétien
sauvé par grâce ?
Voici une question
qui a fait et continuera
à faire couler
beaucoup d'encre.
C'est un vaste sujet
que nous commencerons
à aborder ce matin
et que nous aurons l'occasion
de creuser
dans les prochains versets
de cette lettre.
Nous devons rester
tous très vigilants
face à ces deux erreurs dangereuses
que sont le légalisme
et l'antinomisme.
Peut-être avez-vous tendance
à vous dire que,
puisque Jésus a accompli
la loi pour vous,
vous n'y êtes plus soumis
ou qu'en tout cas,
votre niveau d'obéissance
à la loi
n'a plus aucune importance
devant Dieu.
À l'inverse,
vous avez peut-être
tendance à entretenir
un rapport névrotique
avec la loi
et à vous sentir coupable
jusqu'à penser
que Dieu pourrait
vous rejeter,
voire même
vous retirer votre salut,
vous renier en tant
que son enfant
si vous n'obéissez pas
suffisamment
à la loi.
Mais l'expérience
du chrétien
face à la loi
est tout autre
et repose sur un équilibre
biblique
magnifiquement cohérent
et reposant
pour notre âme.
Cela dit,
l'emphase de Jacques
dans ses versets
est très clairement
de nous mettre en garde
contre une certaine
conception
et mise en pratique
de la loi.
Face à notre incapacité
à obéir parfaitement
à la loi,
nous avons tous
la tendance
comme il le dit
quelques versets
plus haut
à nous tromper
par de faux raisonnements,
à refaçonner la loi
pour qu'elle semble
moins nous condamner,
pour qu'elle soit
plus facile
à accomplir pour nous.
Nous gardons
ce qui nous arrange,
nous occultons
ou nous diminuons
l'importance
de ce qui nous embarrasse,
nous élevons
certains commandements
auxquels nous pensons
bien obéir
au-dessus d'autres
pour contrebalancer
notre désobéissance,
et c'est contre
cette vaine négociation
de notre chair
avec la loi de Dieu
que Jacques nous met en garde
dans ses versets
8 à 11.
Et je vous propose
donc d'aborder
cette mise en garde
en suivant
les trois points suivants.
Une loi
à l'image
de Dieu,
une loi
qui nous condamne
impitoyablement,
une loi
accomplie
parfaitement.
Il n'y a pas
de loi
sans législateur.
Et une loi
est toujours
à l'image
de son législateur.
Elle est le reflet
de sa personnalité.
Elle est l'expression
de ses convictions,
de ses objectifs.
Et c'est donc par là
que nous allons commencer
une loi
à l'image
de Dieu,
son législateur.
Nous parlons
de loi,
de commandement,
mais
d'où vient
cette loi
et
qu'est-elle ?
S'agit-il
de tout l'Ancien Testament ?
des cinq livres
du Pentateuch ?
Des 600 lois juives ?
Des dix commandements
uniquement ?
Puisque Jacques
parle dans ses versets
d'accomplir
ou de
transgresser
la loi,
je crois qu'il est
important pour nous
de savoir
ce qu'est essentiellement
la loi.
Et pour répondre
à cela,
nous devons remonter
jusqu'aux origines
de notre univers
lorsque Dieu
le créa
par sa parole.
Notre Dieu
est un Dieu
d'ordre,
de hiérarchie,
de variété
et de stabilité.
Il a laissé
des signes,
des indices,
des témoignages,
il a laissé son empreinte
dans toute sa création.
C'est pour cela
que l'apôtre Paul
affirme
que tout homme
est inexcusable
devant Dieu
car,
Romain 1,
verset 20,
depuis la création
du monde,
les perfections
invisibles de Dieu,
sa puissance éternelle
et sa divinité
se voient
comme à l'œil nu
quand on les considère
dans ses ouvrages.
Avant que la création
ne soit corrompue
à la suite du péché
d'Adam et Ève,
tout ce que Dieu
avait créé
était très bon.
Toute la création
jusqu'à la moindre particule
obéissait parfaitement
et constamment
à la volonté
prescriptive de Dieu.
C'est-à-dire
qu'absolument
tout était conforme
au standard
de fonctionnement
et de moralité
que Dieu avait établi
pour sa création
dans son infinie sagesse
et selon
sa seule volonté.
Ces standards
sur lesquels
furent fondées
la création
par Dieu,
c'est ce que nous appelons
l'ordre créationnel.
Lorsqu'Adam et Ève
qui étaient encore
purs moralement
contemplaient
cette création,
cet ordre créationnel,
il était alors
naturel pour eux
de comprendre
et de faire
la volonté de Dieu
et de se conformer
parfaitement
à cet ordre créationnel.
Ils n'étaient pas tentés
en eux-mêmes
de s'en éloigner,
d'être
ou de faire
autre chose
que ce pour quoi
ils étaient censés,
que ce qu'ils étaient
censés être
et censés faire,
c'est-à-dire
glorifier Dieu
sur terre
et prendre plaisir
en lui
éternellement.
Avant d'être
tentés par le diable
et de finir
par désobéir à Dieu,
ils accomplissaient
parfaitement
ce que nous appelons
la loi naturelle
qui n'est rien d'autre
que le respect
absolu
de la volonté de Dieu
gravé et révélé
dans l'ordre créationnel,
dans la création.
si la loi
est à l'image
de Dieu
et que l'homme
est à l'image
de Dieu,
alors nous sommes
à l'image
de la loi.
Avant la chute,
nature humaine
et loi naturelle
ne faisaient qu'un.
L'homme
respirait la loi,
pensait la loi,
parlait la loi,
marchait
selon la loi.
C'est un point
très important
pour la suite.
Avant la chute,
Adam et Ève
n'avaient pas besoin
d'un code civil
tel que les dix commandements.
Ils vivaient
naturellement
et instinctivement
en suivant
les principes
des dix commandements.
En dehors
de l'interdiction
de manger du fruit,
de l'arbre,
de la connaissance,
du bien et du mal,
ils n'avaient pas besoin
d'avertissement,
de discipline
ou de menaces
de jugement
contre des péchés spécifiques
puisqu'en suivant
les inclinations naturelles
de leur chair
alors moralement pure.
Ils vivaient
en tout point
selon la volonté
de Dieu.
La loi
était leur vie
et leur vie
était conforme
à la loi.
Contrairement à nous,
aujourd'hui,
leur nature humaine
encore immaculée
les poussait naturellement
à aimer Dieu
de tout leur être
et leurs prochains
comme eux-mêmes.
C'est-à-dire
à accomplir
la loi royale
que Jacques mentionne
au verset 8
ou encore
toute la loi
selon le résumé
que Christ lui-même
en fait par ses deux commandements
aimer Dieu
et son prochain
comme eux-mêmes.
La loi
n'apparaît pas
sur le Mont-Sinai
avec Moïse
et elle ne disparaît pas
avec l'incarnation
de Jésus-Christ
qui affirme à lui-même
il est plus facile
que le ciel
et la terre passent
qui ne l'est
qu'à un seul trait
un seul trait
de l'être de la loi
viennent à tomber.
La loi existait
avant la création du monde
et elle existera
dans l'éternité.
Elle ne peut pas disparaître
car elle est fondamentalement
l'expression
de la volonté immuable
du seul vrai Dieu
qui en est
le législateur.
Voilà donc
la première chose
à retenir.
La loi n'est pas
essentiellement
une liste de péchés
à ne pas commettre
pour ne pas être puni
et d'obligation
à remplir
pour être béni.
La loi
est dans son essence
l'expression
législative
de la volonté
parfaite
du Dieu
immuable
pour le bien
de ses créatures.
Et avant la chute
Adam et Ève
observaient naturellement
toute cette loi
pour leur plus grand bien.
Si la loi
est l'expression
de la volonté
de Dieu
pour ses créatures
elle reflète donc
qui il est
sa nature
ses attributs
et c'est ce que nous allons
voir maintenant.
Dieu est éternel
comme nous
l'avons lu
de la bouche
de Christ lui-même
sa loi
l'est aussi.
Dieu est immuable
il ne change pas
sa loi
ne change pas non plus.
Dieu est bon
sa loi
l'est aussi.
Dieu est juste
sa loi
l'est aussi.
Dieu est lumière
sa loi
l'est aussi.
Et le plus important
pour nous ce matin
Dieu est
simple
sa loi
elle est aussi.
Je fais le pari
que plusieurs d'entre vous
pensent que je viens
d'affirmer que Dieu
est simple dans le sens
basique
naïf
élémentaire.
Mais je vous rassure
ce n'est pas ce que je dis
Dieu n'a rien de simple
dans ce sens.
Il est bien évidemment
infiniment au-delà
des vérités
les plus complexes
que l'esprit humain
le plus intelligent
le plus brillant
pourrait comprendre
et saisir.
Lorsque nous affirmons
que Dieu est simple
nous disons que Dieu
est
identique
à son être
et à ses attributs
ce que Dieu a
comme qualité
attribut
perfection
il est
ses attributs
ses qualités
et ses perfections.
Dieu est un être
absolument un
sans partie
sans composition
son essence
est identique
à l'existence
et à ses attributs
de sorte que
tout ce que Dieu est
Dieu l'est pleinement
et indivisiblement.
La justice
l'amour
la bonté
la puissance
et tous les autres
attributs de Dieu
ne sont pas des réalités
séparées
plus ou moins
grandes
plus ou moins présentes
en Dieu
mais une seule
et même réalité
parfaite
Dieu n'est pas composé
il n'est pas morcelé
il n'est pas
un ensemble
constitué
d'une petite part
de justice
d'une plus grande
part d'amour
d'une petite part
de patience
il est l'essence
de la justice
de la patience
il est l'essence
de l'amour
et tout cela
dans une égale mesure
et donc
sa justice
est patiente
son amour
est juste
est patient
vous comprenez
c'est cela
la doctrine
de la simplicité
divine
Dieu est un
et ne peut être
morcelé
compartimenté
divisé
et bien tout comme
Dieu n'est ni composé
ni morcelé
ni compartimenté
ni divisé
sa loi n'est pas
morcelée
en commandement
indépendant
les uns des autres
elle est
unie
et elle constitue
à l'image
de son législateur
une seule
et même réalité
parfaite
la loi est à l'image
de son législateur
un ensemble
indivisible
la loi est donc
la révélation
de la volonté
de Dieu
pour sa création
et elle est
à l'image
de son législateur
une entité
un ensemble
indivisible
voici sur quelle base
nous pouvons avancer
en voyant maintenant
pourquoi
et comment
cette loi
nous condamne
impitoyablement
alors vous me direz
quand même
c'est un peu osé
d'affirmer que la loi
est une et indivisible
lorsqu'on voit
tant de lois
différentes
dans l'Ancien Testament
et puis
n'est-il pas clair
dans la parole
qu'il y a des péchés
plus graves
que d'autres
en fait
la Bible
affirme clairement
ces deux réalités
la loi
est un ensemble
indivisible
et certains péchés
sont en effet
plus graves
que d'autres
et ce sont
deux réalités
qui comme nous allons le voir
n'ont rien de contradictoire
ces versets
que nous étudions
ce matin
dans Jacques
prouve
facilement
l'indivisibilité
de la loi
comme nous allons le voir
au verset 10
mais commençons par voir
ce que dit le reste
des écritures
sur la différence
de gravité
entre les péchés
pour qu'il y ait
des péchés
plus graves
que d'autres
il faut qu'il y ait
des commandements
plus importants
que d'autres
car le péché
n'est rien d'autre
que la transgression
des commandements
de Dieu
et c'est ce que
notre Seigneur
enseigna
dans son reproche
aux pharisiens
il leur dit
vous avez négligé
les choses
les plus importantes
de la loi
la justice
la miséricorde
et la fidélité
et il s'ensuit
que ceux qui transgressent
ces choses
les plus importantes
de la loi
commettent
des péchés
plus graves
comme le souligna
aussi notre Seigneur
Jésus
lors de son arrestation
Jésus répondit
tu n'aurait sur moi
aucun pouvoir
s'il ne t'avait été donné
d'en haut
c'est pourquoi
celui qui me livre
à toi
commet un plus grand
péché
et qui dit péché
plus grave
dit
châtiment plus sévère
et l'auteur
de la lettre aux Hébreux
nous dit
de quel châtiment
plus sévère
pensez-vous
que sera jugé
digne
celui qui aura foulé
aux pieds
le Fils de Dieu
et ce principe
aura des répercussions
jusque dans l'éternité
puisque pour finir
comme l'affirme Jésus Christ
le jour du jugement
Tyre et Sidon
seront traités
moins sévèrement
que vous
il est donc très clair
qu'il y a une gradation
dans l'importance
des commandements
de la loi
donc dans la gravité
des péchés
et donc dans le châtiment
qu'il mérite
et on retrouve
ce principe
dans les lois du Pentateuch
où tous les péchés
sont condamnés certes
mais ne méritent pas
tous la même sang
par exemple
l'adultère
est puni de mort
mais le vol
est passible
de châtiment corporel
ou civil
et non de mort
il s'agit
d'une justice
graduée
où la sentence
est proportionnelle
à la faute
qui a été commise
alors les chrétiens
auxquels
Jacques écrit
pourraient
s'engouffrer
dans cet aspect
graduel de la loi
et lui répondre
bon d'accord
il nous arrive
de mépriser
les pauvres
et de flatter
les riches
c'est vrai
mais comme tu le dis
nous obéissons
à la loi royale
la plus importante
nous aimons
notre prochain
comme nous-mêmes
et puisqu'il s'agit
du plus grand
des commandements
selon Christ lui-même
est-ce que cela
ne vaut pas
bien plus
que de faire
de temps en temps
acception de personne
mais cet argumentaire
ne tient pas
une seconde
face à ces versets
de Jacques
premièrement
il n'y a rien
de plus opposé
à l'amour
de son prochain
tel que la Bible
le définit
que l'acception
de personne
je vous ai rappelé
l'emphase
que nous avions
mise dans les dernières
prédications
sur la convoitise
de gloire
qui a poussé Satan
à s'élever contre Dieu
et à faire chuter l'homme
mais il n'y a pas
que cela
qui a motivé Satan
dans sa rébellion
et dans sa tentation
la Bible nous montre
clairement
deux choses
au sujet
des anges
dont Satan
pour rappel
était le plus grand
et le plus beau
ces deux choses
sont les suivantes
les anges
sont des créatures
supérieures aux hommes
mais elles sont aussi
envoyées par Dieu
pour servir
les hommes
et de nombreux théologiens
voient ici
ce qui a pu pousser
Satan
et les anges
qui l'ont suivi
à se rebeller
contre Dieu
ils ne pouvaient supporter
!
d'être au service
de créatures
si inférieures
à elles
à leurs yeux
et n'est-ce pas là
encore une fois
l'essence
du péché
d'acception de personne
refuser
d'honorer
et encore plus
de servir
ceux que nous méprisons
au fond de nous-mêmes
que nous jugeons
trop insignifiants
trop inférieurs
trop indignes
de notre considération
et de notre service
sur la base
de critères
charnels
et frères et sœurs
dites-moi
si les anges
furent jetés
en enfer
par Dieu
sans aucun
espoir
de rédemption
parce qu'ils
refusèrent
de servir
et d'honorer
des créatures
qui sont
objectivement
inférieures
à eux
que dire
de nous
lorsque nous
refusons
de nous servir
et de nous
honorer
les uns
les autres
parce que nous
considérons
notre frère
indigne
de notre
considération
alors que nous
sommes tous
semblables
non seulement
en tant qu'être
humain
mais encore
plus
en tant qu'être
humain
uni
et caché
en Christ
ne faisons-nous
pas alors preuve
d'un orgueil
encore plus grand
que celui
des anges
et notre
exception
de personne
n'en est-elle
pas encore
plus ignoble
aux yeux
de notre Dieu
donc même
si les dessinataires
de Jacques
tentaient de masquer
leur péché
d'acception
de personne
sous leur
soi-disant
amour
de leur prochain
cette défense
serait déjà
anéantie
simplement
par la nature
même de ce péché
d'acception
de personne
qui est totalement
contradictoire
et incompatible
avec l'amour
du prochain
tel que la Bible
le définit
c'est aussi
l'avis de Jean Calvin
qui commande ce passage
ainsi
Jacques
dit que
ce n'est point
aimer les prochains
que de choisir
par ambition
une partie
et de laisser là
les autres
oui mais Jacques
c'est quand même
la loi royale
que nous accomplissons
pourra dire
ces chrétiens
non
car premièrement
ce n'est pas vrai
que vous l'accomplissez
car vous ne pouvez pas
à la fois
aimez votre prochain
comme vous même
comme il est dit
au verset 8
et l'avis lire
comme il est dit
au verset 6
et deuxièmement
imaginons un instant
que les deux
soient compatibles
ce n'est pas
parce que vous obéissez
à un commandement
fusse le plus grand
que cela vous dispense
d'obéir aux autres
ou vous permet
d'en transgresser certains
car verset 10
quiconque observe
toute la loi
mais pêche
contre un seul commandement
devient coupable
de tous
Jacques
abat ici
sa carte maîtresse
et porte un coup fatal
à toute forme
de légalisme
avec cet argument
imparable
celui qui parviendrait
imaginons
à observer
toute la loi
mais viendrait
à pécher
une seule fois
contre un seul commandement
fût-ce le moins important
serait coupable
de transgression
envers tous
les commandements
de la loi
pourquoi
nous l'avons dit
tout à l'heure
car la loi
est à l'image
de son législateur
le Dieu
simple
elle est une
et indivisible
il est impossible
d'en transgresser
une partie
sans entacher
toutes les autres
il est impossible
d'en accomplir
une partie
sans l'accomplir
dans son ensemble
peut-être
certains parmi vous
se disent
bon
il faudrait savoir
Nathanaël
tu nous dis
qu'il y a
des commandements
plus importants
que d'autres
donc des péchés
plus graves
qui méritent
la mort
et d'autres
moins graves
qui ne méritent
pas la mort
dans l'ancien testament
et puis maintenant
tu nous dis
que commettre
une seule fois
même le moins grave
des péchés
revient à les commettre
tous
même les plus grands
la parole de Dieu
est riche
frères et sœurs
et nous la méditerons
toute notre vie
jusque dans l'éternité
il nous faut maintenant
revenir à la base
que nous avons posée
tout à l'heure
la loi
est l'expression
législative
de la volonté
parfaite
du Dieu
simple
et immuable
pour le bien
de ses créatures
cette loi
est à l'image
de son législateur
éternel
immuable
indivisible
il est donc
impossible
de prétendre
l'accomplir
en y obéissant
qu'en partie
comme le commente
aussi Jean Calvin
il ne nous est pas
licite ou autorisé
de retrancher
de la loi
de Dieu
ce qui ne nous plaira
point
c'est parce que
la loi
est la révélation
de sa volonté
immuable
et indivisible
que la seule
obéissance
que notre Dieu
trois fois saint
peut accepter
c'est une obéissance
parfaite
qui nommait
et ne transgresse
aucun commandement
de sa loi
Dieu ne veut
point être
servi
à moitié
continue
Jean Calvin
et cela n'est pas
un caprice
de la part
de Dieu
on ne peut pas
morceler
la volonté
de Dieu
donc on ne peut
pas morceler
sa loi
donc on ne peut
pas y obéir
en partie seulement
cette obéissance
parfaite
nous l'avons vu
elle était naturelle
pour Adam et Ève
avant leur chute
la nature humaine
était définie
même
par cette conformité
parfaite
à la loi de Dieu
et l'accomplissement
total de la loi
la nature de Dieu
et sa loi
la nature de l'homme
et son obéissance
à la loi
tout cela formait
un ensemble
parfaitement unifié
et harmonieux
avant la chute
absolument
tout ce que l'homme
faisait
avant la chute
participait
à glorifier Dieu
et à trouver
sa joie suprême
en lui
toutes les activités
qui composaient
la vie de l'homme
avait pour point
de départ
et pour point
d'arrivée
l'amour pour Dieu
et pour son prochain
si l'on vous demande
ce qu'est l'homme
ce qu'est la nature humaine
vous pouvez répondre
aimer Dieu
et aimer son prochain
comme soi-même
voilà ce que
chaque être humain
devrait être
car avant d'être
un rappel légal
nécessaire
face au péché
de notre chair corrompue
la loi
est tout simplement
la description
de la nature
et de la vie humaine
telle que Dieu
les a créées
au départ
voilà pourquoi
frères et sœurs
la loi royale
dont parle Jacques
au verset 8
n'est pas juste
le plus grand
des commandements
c'est bien plus
que cela
c'est l'identité
même de la loi
c'est le but
de la loi
la source de la loi
la colonne vertébrale
le tronc
la sève
de la loi
tous les commandements
de Dieu
nous rappellent
ce que serait
notre nature
et notre vie
sans le péché
et comment nous
devrions vivre
en aimant Dieu
de tout notre être
et notre prochain
comme nous-mêmes
voilà pourquoi
toute la loi
dépend d'aimer Dieu
et notre prochain
comme nous-mêmes
car ce double amour
c'est le point de départ
et le point d'arrivée
de chaque commandement
de la loi
pour citer
une dernière fois
Jean Calvin
et selon mon jugement
elle est appelée
la loi royale
comme on dit
le chemin royal
c'est-à-dire
le grand chemin
sur lequel
on ne saurait faillir
et où on peut marcher
sûrement
ainsi la loi royale
est pour ainsi dire
comme la doctrine
complète
et unique
qui est ainsi
appelée en opposition
au circuit dangereux
et aux détours obscurs
dans lesquels
les hommes
s'égarent
comprenez-vous
ce lien
très important
qu'il y a
entre la loi
et notre nature
humaine
avant la chute
les deux ne faisaient qu'un
après la chute
la loi
simple et immuable
à l'image de Dieu
n'a pas changé
mais nous oui
et donc le rôle
de la loi
devint double
la loi continue
de nous montrer
les hommes et les femmes
que nous devrions être
mais comme nous en sommes
devenus incapables
elles nous condamnent
en même temps
car lorsqu'Adam
a mangé du fruit
défendu
et qu'il a transgressé
un seul
commandement
une seule
instruction de Dieu
c'est toute sa nature
humaine
qui fut corrompue
souillée par le péché
et c'est de cette
dépravation totale
que tous les autres
péchés
découlent
lorsque vous et moi
péchons aujourd'hui
malheureusement
nous ne transgressons pas
uniquement
un commandement
par-ci par-là
mais nous prouvons
avant tout
que nous avons
encore en nous
cette nature humaine
corrompue
qui nous pousse
sans arrêt
à désobéir à la loi
à la volonté de Dieu
le problème du péché
ce n'est pas premièrement
un problème de quantité
un savant calcul
d'addition
de soustraction
de ce que je fais
de bien
de mal
c'est avant tout
un problème de qualité
chacun de nous
a perdu
la pureté originelle
de son humanité
et nous sommes
désormais incapables
d'obéir parfaitement
à toute la loi de Dieu
c'est une tentative
forcément
vouée à l'échec
pour chacun
d'entre nous
voilà pourquoi
il est impossible
d'aimer Dieu
ou son prochain
tout en péchant
contre un
ou plusieurs
commandements
car
aimer Dieu
et son prochain
équivaut précisément
à accomplir parfaitement
toute la loi
nous n'avons
aucune issue
à cette réalité
qui nous condamne tous
nous avons été créés
pour aimer Dieu
le glorifier
de tout notre être
pour aimer
et servir
notre prochain
comme nous-mêmes
notre nature humaine
originelle
vivait ainsi
mais le péché
nous en a rendu
incapable
et étant
de vivre ainsi
nous sommes
chaque jour
condamnés
par la loi
comme des transgresseurs
car pour reprendre
le verset 11
peut-être
ne commettons-nous
pas d'adultère
mais si nous
commettons un meurtre
nous sommes
des transgresseurs
de la loi
voilà
j'ai rassemblé
la triste réalité
de notre humanité
dont aucun de nous
ne peut se soustraire
par ses propres forces
car qui peut changer
sa propre nature
quel léopard
peut effacer
les tâches
de sa fourrure
nous agissons
selon ce que nous sommes
et ce que nous faisons
confirme
et entretient
ce que nous sommes
nous pêchons
car nous sommes pêcheurs
et nos péchés
confirment que nous sommes pêcheurs
et nous condamnent
comme transgresseurs
de la volonté de Dieu
la loi
à laquelle
la nature humaine
se conformait naturellement
avant la chute
ne fait aujourd'hui
que nous montrer
à quel point
notre péché
nous éloigne
toujours plus
de ce que nous devrions être
et faire
en tant qu'hommes
et femmes
créés à l'image de Dieu
pour le glorifier
et aimer
notre prochain
la loi n'a pas changé
car Dieu
n'a pas changé
mais nous avons changé
et tellement changé
que nous sommes désormais
incapables
de vivre
à la hauteur
des standards de Dieu
pour notre plus grand malheur
et le grand malheur
de toute la création
voilà donc pourquoi
et comment la loi
nous condamne
elle reflète
la nature
et les exigences
de son législateur
Dieu
on ne peut la diviser
à notre convenance
et Dieu n'accepte
qu'une obéissance parfaite
dont nous sommes tous
aujourd'hui
incapables
nous sommes donc tous
peu importe notre niveau
d'obéissance à la loi
justement condamnés
par elle
comme ses transgresseurs
!
qui de nous oserait maintenant
prétendre pouvoir être juste
aux yeux de Dieu
en obéissant à la loi
!
seul celui qui rabaisse
les standards de Dieu
ou exagère
son obéissance
le pourrait
cela est en réalité
impossible
car la seule obéissance
que Dieu accepte
est une obéissance
parfaite
et seul un homme
dont la nature humaine
ne serait pas corrompu
par le péché
aurait la capacité
de vivre
sans jamais
enfreindre
la volonté de Dieu
chers frères et sœurs
si vous vous sentiez
triste
et démuni
jusqu'ici
face à ces versets
c'est à la fois
normal et bénéfique
pour vous
car la première étape
d'une vraie compréhension
de l'évangile
et d'une foi chrétienne
authentique
qui mène au salut
c'est la prise de conscience
de la gravité
et des conséquences
terribles
de notre péché
imaginez-vous
ce que cela
devait être
pour Adam
de vivre parfaitement
selon la volonté
de Dieu
sans aucun effort
sans besoin
de menace
de repentance
de correction
sans devoir vivre
avec les conséquences
de son péché
parvenez-vous
à vous
imaginez un monde
rempli d'êtres humains
vivant ainsi
aimant Dieu
de tout leur être
et leurs prochains
comme eux-mêmes
voilà ce que nous avons
perdu à cause
de notre péché
et nous ne pouvons
rien faire
pour réparer
et reconstruire
ces ruines
quel échec
quelle tristesse
quelle malédiction
n'y a-t-il donc
aucun espoir
la parole de Dieu
nous laisse-t-elle
face à ce constat
tragique
amer
et insoluble
la plupart d'entre vous
je l'espère
savent que ce n'est
pas le cas
car il n'y aurait
sinon
pas d'évangile
l'évangile est
après tout
la bonne nouvelle
d'une victoire
définitive
contre Satan
le péché
et la mort
réjouissons-nous
frères et sœurs
oui car
cette loi
à l'image de Dieu
qui nous condamne
impitoyablement
un homme a réussi
à l'accomplir
parfaitement
à notre place
en effet
parce qu'il est riche
en bonté
en grâce
et en miséricorde
notre grand Dieu
ne nous a pas
laissé livrer
à nous-mêmes
face
au terrible constat
de notre péché
car
Galate 4
verset 4
lorsque les temps
furent accomplis
il a envoyé
son fils
né d'une femme
né sous la loi
afin qu'il
nous racheta
nous
qui étions
sous la loi
oui un nouvel Adam
a bien foulé
la poussière
de cette terre
frères et sœurs
Jésus le Christ
le Messie
l'envoyé de Dieu
Emmanuel
Dieu parmi nous
que de glorieuses
promesses
contenues
dans ces noms
de notre Sauveur
et Seigneur Jésus
Jésus Christ
le second Adam
le représentant
d'une nouvelle humanité
non plus caractérisé
par la désobéissance
et la mort
mais régénéré
pour l'obéissance
et la vie éternelle
c'est ce don
suprême
et immérité
de Dieu
à une humanité
rebelle et pécheresse
que nous célébrerons
dans quelques jours
à l'occasion de Noël
le don de son fils
bien-aimé
venu sur terre
accomplir la loi royale
!
à notre place
et nous purifier
de toutes nos iniquités
par son sang
Hébreu 10
verset 5
c'est pourquoi Christ
entrant dans le monde
dit
voici
je viens
pour faire
ô Dieu
ta volonté
c'est en vertu
de cette volonté
que nous sommes
sanctifiés
par l'offrande
du corps
de Jésus Christ
une fois
pour toutes
car Christ
est la fin
de la loi
pour justifier
tous ceux
qui croient
Jésus
ne fit jamais
exception
de personne
bien au contraire
les pharisiens
lui reprochèrent
même à tort
bien sûr
de côtoyer
des personnes
de mauvaise vie
des pécheurs
qui ne l'aient pas
Jésus
n'eut jamais
une seule mauvaise pensée
un seul mauvais mot
une seule mauvaise attitude
chaque microseconde
de sa vie sur terre
fut un accomplissement
parfait
de toute
la loi de Dieu
il réussit
admirablement
là où le premier Adam
et où chacun d'entre nous
a échoué
terriblement
parce qu'il est vraiment
Dieu
et vraiment homme
le Christ
vécu la vie
que chacun de nous
aurait dû
et devrait vivre
la loi
était sa vie
et toute sa vie
fut conforme
à la loi
je viens pour faire
oh Dieu
ta volonté
ayant désormais
la certitude
par la foi
que Christ a accompli
toute la loi
pour nous
nous sommes
libres
à la fois
de toute
culpabilité
et de tout besoin
d'accomplir la loi
par nous-mêmes
et c'est paradoxalement
cette liberté nouvelle
en Christ
qui nous permet
par le Saint-Esprit
de progresser
dans cette obéissance
joyeuse
que seul le chrétien
peut expérimenter
et cette joie
miraculeuse
ne vient pas
premièrement du fait
que nous nous sentons
de plus en plus
conformes à la loi
mais du fait
de voir
Christ
formé en nous
de voir
notre ancienne nature humaine
corrompue
perdre du terrain
et notre nature humaine
régénérée
à l'image de Christ
gagner du terrain
se renforcer
et s'embellir
de jour en jour
par la grâce de Dieu
le Christ
est venu sur terre
restaurer
sauver
glorifier
sa création
en ruines
et ce merveilleux travail
de restauration
a commencé avec nous
qui sommes
les prémices
de la nouvelle création
le jour vient
frères et sœurs
où nous n'aurons plus
à constater
quotidiennement
les effets du péché
en nous
et ses conséquences
dans notre vie
et celles de nos proches
le jour vient
où ce que nous avons
perdu à cause
de notre péché
sera retrouvé
et même bien au-delà
le jour vient
où la terre
et le ciel
ne feront plus qu'un
où ce culte terrestre
que nous célébrons
et le culte céleste
ne feront plus qu'un
où les anges
et l'humanité glorifiée
ne feront plus qu'un
tous réunis
autour du trône de gloire
de notre sauveur Jésus Christ
vainqueur sur le diable
le péché
et la mort
ce grand jour vient
frères et sœurs
si vous avez capitulé
face à cette loi
qui comme un miroir
vous met face
à la moindre
de vos imperfections
vous montre
à quel point
votre nature
est éloignée
de ce qu'elle devrait être
selon la volonté de Dieu
votre créateur
le législateur
et le souverain du monde
et si après avoir
confessé votre perdition
vous avez saisi
la main pure
du Christ
qui fut percée
pour l'expiation
de vos péchés
alors ce grand jour
qui vient
sera celui
de vos noces
avec l'agneau de Dieu
notre Jésus
nous prépare
une place
dans sa cité céleste
il dresse
en ce moment même
la table
du grand banquet
des noces
qu'il célébrera
avec nous
son église
au grand jour
de son retour
alors frères et sœurs
marchons
main dans la main
sur ce chemin étroit
qui est aussi
la voie royale
vers le ciel
veillons les uns
sur les autres
encourageons-nous
à rester fidèles
à notre foi commune
en gardant les yeux
fixés sur celui
qui a tout accompli
pour notre salut
qui intercède pour nous
et nous accueillera
les bras grands ouverts
au jour de son avènement
le fils de Dieu
est entré humblement
dans le monde
pour venir nous arracher
des griffes
du grand dragon
Satan
certainement
il reviendra en gloire
comme il l'a promis
pour nous emmener vivre
éternellement
avec lui
dans les cieux
Amen
et puis
on va
faire
le